by day guy Davis is a normal college
student but by night he's action guy
where's your costume it doesn't say
anything about a costume party on here
nevermind yes he keeps his fellow
student safe from harm that party Hey
using his superhuman abilities of
detection what I just heard her with my
ears
she said no watch as action guy faces
down his arch-nemesis the nefarious jock
man is actually my teammate and my
friend nemesis weird vibes from the
Steve in the other room Emily are you
walking home for the good of all the
students he is the shining beacon of
justice
he is back channel whatever action guy
let me go hey hey
daddy and introducing action yeah
you do get out here I was just leaving
[Music]